[Music]
Resident Evil 2 has finally been
released from Capcom this is a remake of
the 1998 game of the same title there
was originally a remake of the first
Resident Evil that was released at
GameCube and had great success but
despite this game success there was no
subsequent remake of the sequel until
now if you've been following my channel
for a while you know that I love this
series the survival horror aspect is
always one of my favorite themes in
videogames and this one in particular I
was equally excited for and concerned
because I really didn't want them to
tarnish the original I didn't want to
play some revamped version of it that
didn't understand why the original is so
good but I was excited to see that they
had changed certain things there's no
longer tank controls this is a
third-person perspective rather than
fixed camera angles which changes the
way that zombies can scare you because
in the original Resident Evil games
those fixed camera angles obscured
things that were in the corner because
you couldn't look there and the zombie
would just start walking towards you and
it's like this horrific moment but
without the fixed camera angles they had
to go in and really play around with
lighting and the positioning of people
throughout rooms also as I played this
game something that continuously got on
my nerves in a good way is that you will
kill a zombie at least you think you do
and that motherfucker just comes right
back to life sometimes you'll kill him
he's dead
you leave the room you come back hours
later and this motherfucker pops out of
the corner and it's just it's it's
horrible and I loved it with this game
you can play as either Claire or Leon
and both characters offer a different
perspective to the game which gives you
a very immersive feeling to the world
created here I played as Claire my first
playthrough and that's the playthrough
that I'm reviewing I'm still gonna go
and play as Leon but I felt that playing
all the way through the game as one of
them was sufficient enough to talk about
the games worth she finds herself in the
famed Raccoon City where an outbreak has
occurred and this viral infection has
spread zombies are everywhere and she
eventually gets trapped in a police
station
an old museum that was converted into a
police station so there's
tons of rooms things underground things
above ground and there's so many rooms
to explore so many things to do and I
found myself getting really invested in
it I had such a great time playing this
whenever I buy a new game I always stare
at it and I think this cost 60 bucks
just please be good just just make me
happy just make me feel good about about
life just just give that to me and about
an hour into the game I sat there and I
said god damn this game is good I am
satisfied I got so into the game I
didn't want to do much of anything else
and it's funny because the game doesn't
waste too much time with cutscenes or
elaborate story it just really wants you
to have a blast and it wants you to feel
like you're in this environment and the
best Resident Evil games are just like
that they create an immersive feeling in
the atmosphere the locale you just
really feel like you're there and you
don't really feel like leaving you just
want to keep exploring and learning
things and solving puzzles and some of
them are really ingenious actually I had
a great time with the game it's very
faithful in certain ways to the original
but the things that have been altered
loved it I feel like they've improved it
actually and while the game is an action
heavy per se like say Resident Evil 4
which is probably my favorite of the
more action centric Resident Evil titles
there is a considerable amount of combat
it's just that you have to conserve ammo
very carefully and there's a lot of
weapons that I had a really fun time
with like the spark shot frying zombies
with that was highly satisfying in an
almost disturbing way and I'm fine with
that
I also love the way Claire reacted to
zombies when she was trying to kill them
she would be like what the fuck what's
your problem asshole that's what I had
say to his zombie too if I was trying to
shoot it in the head seriously though I
liked her character a lot she brought a
levity to a lot of the situations when
she slides down this hill that's filled
with shit and water and just filth in a
sewer she's like oh my god this fucking
sucks it's just I love it I love the
fact that she they made her very real
you know like obviously in real life
most people would probably just be
fleeing the area and screaming and
everything but she's diving into these
situations which makes you like the
character even more but I just liked
that she had such an air of comedy to
her the game is also good at making you
care cuz eventually you come across a
young girl named Cherie that you have to
protect and it's not annoying it's not
like she's a sidekick that you know if
she gets killed next to you or something
it's game over and you have to restart
she doesn't follow you around for a
while you can get a chance to play as
her briefly now it's at this point in
the review that I have to talk about
something very traumatizing that being
the tyrant known as mr. X what the fuck
bro
leave me alone Jesus Christ this guy
just walks through and it's just it's
horrifying
you know you're walking through various
rooms and you can hear him stalking you
through the floors through the walls and
then he just pops out and you can't
fucking kill him and for new players I
would highly recommend not wasting your
ammo on him just get the fuck out
cuz go away from wherever he is and you
will be happier trust me
the game has a great way of making you
feel panicked and it's not just because
the game is horrifying necessarily it's
more about the way the game is built and
the mechanics of it Limited ammo where a
save is what you need to do something
this guy is following you but you have
to move these bookcases and he's right
there and you just have to keep circling
the room hoping that eventually he will
lose track of you like things like that
that challenge the way we view horror in
video games which is what the best
Resident Evil games do as far as living
up to the original I feel this surpasses
it as being a modern game after a
thousand other zombie games this is
still best of the bunch I love this game
I had such a great time with it I
definitely recommend it especially if
you loved the Resident Evil titles I'm
gonna give Resident Evil to a nine point
five out of ten I have only one small
little nitpick with the game and it's
basically the lighting her flashlights
in hallways sometimes is just not
powerful enough and I found myself
squinting a lot and trying to look at
things and I get that that's also sort
of a part of the game it makes it more
scary but after a while it was like I
need up just a little more light that's
the tiniest little nitpick I have with
the game and that's about it
I would really recommend you guys
checking this out thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you
[Music]